hello everyone and welcome to tonight's
lecture i'm your host its frame master
you guys for Sarah 1 i'll be with you
for an hour i'm here at st. Louis chess
club and scholastic center where the
live audience proud of me and we do a
lot of innovative things here at the
same others chess club and this is the
first time that we've ever tried to do I
didn't lie
stream and so we're going to have a fun
I'm finding out how it's all going to
work tonight especially about the
upcoming 2015 us chess championships to
be played here in the San Jose chest
plugins classic center it will begin on
april first will be the first round and
it's Anna
u.s. chess championships you can follow
all of the action move by move at us
chess champs calm and i'm also i have
another monitor gear that is open to
accept questions from Twitter feeds at
hashtag alexa judge chance so please
participate the 2015 US championships
are going to be the strongest
championships ever held in the united
states and I speak authoritative Lee has
I'd 14 of them and this championship is
just amazing not since the days of Bobby
Fischer and Samuel chefs key have we
seen two top players in the world toon
world's top Templars
stay competing with international
they are harmed Nakamura with a long
time number one
there's going to be challenged by Wesley
so Wesley so long Philippines last year
he changed Federation's from the
philippines to the united states and
he'll be making his debut in the u.s.
championships at this moment hikaru is
Sigma sitting on a career high he is the
third highest rated player in the world
and Wesley is number seven also at a
career high however if you think this is
going to be two horse race only you'll
be a quite mistaken there are some
really wild kg veterans in the field not
the least of which is our defending
champion gata kamsky fer gotta the st.
Louis chess club has been a kind of a
second home he is going to be trying for
his fifth US Championship title out of
six oh pardon me he won it he's won at
five times here in st. Louis the only
time he didn't win it was when he lost
to Hikaru in 2013 I believe as a prelude
to the games i'm going to look at it to
the US Championship we're going to look
some games that had decided the US
Championship in the past but first I'd
like to go down the field and again a
very very fantastic field of players we
have Alex only show Alex I think he's
sandbagging with a 2670 rating on oh by
the way I wanted to mention that half
the field in the u.s. championships are
are in the top 100 players of the world
half the field that's incredible and
it's an all grandmaster field as well it
will be a round-robin 12-player round
robin and all grandmasters Alex only
shook alex has played in quite a number
of World Team Championships and US
Olympic teams and he has just been a
rock for the team very very steady
player super solid doesn't win a lot of
games very very rarely
rose and most often is in the top half
of the field and he'll be looking to
make a statement in this championship
also we have vara cobian bar is also
like myself on a rotation here at the
st. Louis chess club as a grandmaster in
Resident last year he tied for first
along with Alex Linderman gadar kempski
var1 the right to get into the finals
against gotta and lost to gain the rapid
chess a two-game rapid chess match one
and a half half we'll look at those
games in a moment continuing through the
field I might say that team organi of
team are is just an amazing player he's
extraordinarily gifted talented
attacking player he loves sharp
calculating positions and if he gets the
type of positions he wants he could be a
real formidable force in the tournament
the rest of it the field almost looks
like the danger squad of unbelievably
talented juniors we have ray Robson
who's represented the united states
already on olympic team competitions
twice the collegiate champion of the
United States Daniel na Radetzky daniel
has been going at a rapid clip only
recently he broke into the 2600 he's now
up to 26 33 it seems to me in nearly
every event that Daniel nordisk he's
competing he's gaining rating points as
it is in fact most of the danger squad
continuing we have Sam shanklin Sam just
played in the Tata Steel chess festival
he went through a very strong field in
the Challenger section undefeated he had
at least three very very good positions
that had he converted those he could
have easily tied for first Sam also want
a gold
metal for the US olympic team in tromso
norway and he's been writing a high in
fact everybody in the field actually
seems to be at their career Peaks then
we have Kayden trove who was qualified
as the US junior champion as we know
Kayden one of the great talents in the
United States in the last three years
he's really been exceptional competed
for the United States and the world
youth championships where he's won a
gold medal we have the US open champion
Conrad hold from Texas Conrad played
last year in the u.s. championships and
he enjoyed himself very much looking to
improve his performance over last year
and finally we have the wild card the
organizers get one player of their
choice and we have had and we have Sam
sebi on Sam seve on is the youngest
Grandmaster in American history he got
his grand master title here last year in
st. Louis where he competed and got his
rating over 2,500 Sam also was competing
in the Tata Steel chess festival in 2015
in January did incredibly well much
better than I expected first time out of
the box he is a force to be reckoned
with so an incredible field and as mr. t
predicted pain I predict lots of upsets
in this US Championship on the ladies
draw we have also a really compelling
field arena crush has been dominating
women's chests in the United States for
quite a number of years her closest
rival on asset on ski has at times upset
her but Anna is not in the field this
year we do have a young lady who
transferred from Belle
rusa her name is Anna Sheridan she will
be competing along with Katya abria
abrahamyan Sabina voice there too
Katerina nemcova nasty policy Alisa
Malkina route it's really nice to see
Julie and gold honey lucid on gold itani
back in the field she's taking a break
of blade to raise some children so it
would be very nice to have her back
victorian may will be back anyway
approve of her coud Jennifer you those
three are all wild card contestants so
12 players in both fields single
round-robin and 11 rounds of fighting
chess it all begins in April and again
on us Chester champs com you can follow
all of the moves all of the games all of
the rounds live there'll be three
commentators our hostess will be a
jennifer Shah hottie for women's
Grandmaster and a friend and colleague
Grandmaster Maurice Ashley as well as
myself so we three will be doing the
live comment rate and again for chess
champs calm and you can join and ask any
questions through the hashtag chess
champs on twitter us just us chess chaps
pardon me twitter let me get to some of
the games and i was looking in my
database because i was really really
curious how wesley so and hikaru
nakamura matched up in their classical
fights i had just watched on the chess
chess calm the so-called death match
between these two players where they
play five minute three minute one
and it seemed to me that Hikaru was the
decisive winner but especially so in the
bullet chest and the games were very
competitive but he Caro had an edge in
does blitz in the deathmatch remarkably
I still somehow kind of surprised by
this they've in my database I could only
find a single game that they had played
in tournament competition they played
last year in vikon's a in 2014 9 2015
but in 2014 and Wesley so was white it
was a rather nervy affair I would say as
both players played a very tight closed
game and hikaru he likes to play
different variations of the semi soft
it's very very hard to guess what hikaru
is going to do in his defense sometimes
he plays a Leningrad Dutch sometimes he
just plays straight nims Oh Indian or
Queens gambit declined in this game
before a bishop before now efore is
really the prelude to a very sharp
gambit that goes as follows Queen takes
d4 capturing the pawn bishop takes and
Queen takes e4 chat Bishop e2 in this
position there's been a lot of tries for
black essentially white has the forest
pond as the key idea of bringing us
queen to d6 to set up various mating
threats as well as to castle
theoretically black has actually been
doing quite alright and the
battles but still it really you really
need to know your theory extraordinarily
well if you're going to enter this
terrain so I found it rather interesting
that Hikaru ducked the discussion and
played Bishop b4 that's good I'm a
little bit skeptical of the move but
actually it's not that bad a move in a
certain way it kind of looks like a
French defence a French winter work
except black has a pawn on c6 white has
a pawn on c4 and I would think that this
would favor white Wesley played efore a5
not the only move by the way i think ii
five is an excellent choice don't get me
wrong in comparison with a winner work I
was just thinking about the move Queen
g4 Knight f6 Queen takes g7 g8 again
we're following a pattern of the winter
were where this pawn is on c2 and black
spawn is on c7 and I was trying to
figure out which side benefited the most
I I came to the conclusion that it was
actually two whites benefit but after
night GE 2 i'm not a how-to % sure that
white has any big claims of an advantage
for example after Queen f6 or even after
c5 I think both of those moves are quite
good
good enough for a balanced game so e5 is
definitely a normal move c5 again it
looks like a linear or accept this pawn
is on c4 instead of c2 in some strange
way thanks to the palm being on c4
normally in the winter were black always
has a problem it's actually called the
problem Bishop how it will ever get
developed but thanks to the tension
between the pawns on d5 and ce4 blacks
bishop is not going to be a very passive
won the game continued takes takes a
three days two eggs so white is kind of
happy he's won the two bishops he's got
a safe center things seem to be going
this way however once the players
reached this position after this
interesting waiting move h7 h6 a kind of
prophylactic move white had a serious
problem to solve the question for white
is what is he going to do with this dark
squared bishop on the one hand placing
the bishop on v2 doesn't feel very
satisfactory after all in that way it
doesn't have much of a view and it's
only playing a defensive role also if
you play Bishop e3 you're making the
bishop vulnerable to a possible night f5
and maybe the bishop isn't at its best
on an e3 so it's not really a question
of do we develop the bishop along the c
1g5 what square do we pick I actually
thought or let's say the move up I would
have anticipated was like in many for
positions the move a 3 a 4 in this case
white is opening up the diagonal very
nicely for his dark squared bishop to go
from a 3-2 FA and I thought that that
would have put more pressure on blacks
position instead Wesley chose a very a
creepy slow soft move which is actually
quite good as well many times in such
structures it's important for black to
get counter play based on the c4 square
can get a Knight to c4 especially so the
bishop on the bishop coming to d2 rather
discourages that plan in the first place
because it makes the be four square
available secondly white could
potentially capture the night so Bishop
d2 was the choice of Wesley and the game
continued Bishop at five queen bee three
very very logical move light puts
pressure on both the pawns on b7 as well
as d5 and now it's almost kind of like a
stutter step bishop came to g4 so you'd
almost have to ask yourself the question
well why didn't he hikaru play that move
right away well he did it for very
specific reason and that reason was that
he wanted to learn that the dark square
Bishop to the square c 3 which he
successfully has so that when he brings
a rook to the C file it won't be that
easy for white to oppose the room
after Bishop see 327 h3 Bishop e6 why
Bishop e6 and not back to f5 I actually
was not sure myself in fact if we go
back just a move or two right here when
he Carl played the move Bishop g4 I was
actually thinking because now I'm going
to make a comparison with chiro cons
advanced cargo compositions up the move
Bishop b4 move Bishop b4 looks a little
bit better you still have the same
threat but at the same time after you
put your night on on f5 the pawn on d4
is hang so let's just play a few moves
so I can show you what I mean now after
for example Queen B to this may have
been the reason that persuaded you Carl
not to play Bishop b4 in the sense that
white has ideas like 92 in the position
to eliminate the strong light square
Bishop in the game
what happened was Bishop g4 the ship's
III queen d 7 h 3 bishop came back to e6
in an intriguing way I I rather like the
fact that white had played h2 h3 and
from the Congress point of view remember
before when I said that he'd learned the
bishop to the C 3 square he did it for a
specific reason as well as the C file
but also to potentially hot with the
Knight to f4 now that the pawns on age
three there's a little bit of a target
in the sense that if white black and
arrangers of pieces for Bishop takes h3
sacrifice white has to be careful about
that this move in my opinion was a
really egregious error I just I really
Wesley Wesley what on earth were you
thinking when you brought your up to D 1
I really don't like that move one bit
and I thought rook on f1 to be one ! was
so much stronger with this move rookie
one everything fits from White's point
of view first of all white has an
obvious battery and he's attacking upon
the seven light really wants to learn
that pawn ahead it might you might think
what's the problem I just played the
move b6 everything is okay but look a
little bit closer and you see instantly
immediately that two very important
light squares on the queenside have been
weakened so for example white would play
a four with ideas of a five getting his
roof in the game also ideas of bishop a6
as well as Bishop to b5 so I think after
the move rookie one black is actually in
a bit of trouble
words I think black has a worst game for
example rook to be eight if you don't
like the move be six then you have to
play the movie eight and now here's the
point of work on f1 to be one as opposed
to rook a be one now you get to play
Bishop b4 and suddenly White's game is
in full blossom white is threatening
Bishop d6 winning material and after for
example a trade on text now we
understand why we wanted to leave the
rook on a one after a further move for
example a 6b five eight eggs b5 Bishop
takes be fine I really like White's game
very much i think the bishop on e6 is an
excellent block hater but it doesn't
play an active role and i really like
white chances i give him a big plus in
this position none of that happen
instead rook d1 mystifying I do not
understand this move on the contrary I
do understand this move very much night
g6 black has two ideas with this move
the first is first and most obviously he
really likes the idea of playing night
f4 and like I said putting a little
pressure on the h3 pong so there's a
potential sacrifice but even more so
putting the pressure on e5 what do I
mean by that black wants to play f7f 6
and force white to open up
the f file in his favor again the move
rookie one just doesn't fit with what
white is doing Bishop
the move rook c7 was a little bit
confusing because everyone back yes
hello everyone at once again welcome
back through this evening's lecture on
the upcoming US Championships while we
were having our technical difficulties
or just talking with the audience here
in st. Louis about the various plans
that that black could have here and
again I just saw the discussion
revolvers the game being planned yes of
course this is the this is the only game
a classical tournament game that I could
find in my database between the two
highest rated players in the 2015 field
that is to say Wesley so and hikaru
nakamura the game that we we're
witnessing or replaying was played a
year ago in 2014 at the Tata Steel chess
festival and the game as you'll see
ended in a draw we were thinking in
terms of this knight on c6 and Julian
was asking me well what would be the
ideal square and one thought was that
well maybe the night should go to the f5
Square and I was a little skeptical
pointing out that well the night really
doesn't do much there and the in my view
the real ideal square Thor the best
square for the night could be the c-4
square from the sea foursquare will
black could potentially use his Queen
side majority so let's see what happened
in the game rook c7 decimo surprised me
I thought that the maneuver of Hikaru
which was night to g6 was in order to
play the move f
6 tags tags and we get a situation like
this on the board if you take with the
night context let's say you drop that
with the rook let's say white drops back
with his queen in order to sidestep D 5
D for and a potential attacks I thought
this position was pretty even I didn't
think it was that great for black or
gray back great for white but just a raw
the balance game so I was a little bit
surprised by this move rook c7 by Hikaru
which he played ok who excuse me which
he played and just before we had our
technical difficulties I was saying that
I really like this move Queen B to
somehow this move really feels good
first of all you are getting out of this
potential hit so that you know in case
of any night take c 5 D 5 D for your
covering the pawn on d4 more importantly
you're protecting this rook on c1 and
you're setting up yourself up for what I
think is a good move a future Bishop b4
so I like this move a lot and jacaro
decided to play the move Queen e7
it seems like he was holding back on his
idea of f 7 f-6 g2 g3 solid a safe move
if you will White's just trying to limit
any potential hops of white a blacks
night on a very good day white is
hopeful that he'll also be able to
support future advance f2f for at the
moment but not the role of the knight on
f3 is rather passive it it's good there
don't get me wrong but a much better
circuit for example might be on III so
that white might in the near future play
ideas of 91 92 93 and eventually playing
at four I got a lot of arrows on my
screen on we've done rook c8 King h2
again a very safe solid move just kind
of the king is nicely protected over
here and protects the pot on h3 in turn
finally f6 takes takes Bishop g2 so this
Bishop on f1 and didn't have much of a
role in the game is actually starting to
come to life now as soon as the night
drops in on e5 this bishop on g2 will be
eyeballing this pawn on d5 and white
will be very happy in this case 97
Bishop before yes pardon me right here I
didn't like this move Bishop b4 by
Wesley that really in a kind of sense
releases the air out of the position
once all of the rooks come off the
chopping block on the C file I think
whites of chances for advantage really
really declined dramatically it's more
than a more than surprised
that Wesley didn't hop immediately to
the e5 square if for example after 95
there would have been a trade and let's
say Queen f7 don't get me wrong I think
blacks position is still pretty solid
but at least in this case after the move
f2f for we can see that I think that
white is for choice he's got a nicer
pawn structure and he does have after
all the two bishops maybe this fellow on
default c3 slips over here and down the
d6 or even capturing this night instead
after Bishop before everything got
traded and the players oops reached this
position and I actually think they
didn't play this many moons I think that
after 97 a draw was offered in a draw
was agreed to um Hikaru Nakamura very
very rarely offers draws so his offer of
a draw in this particular moment might
have been due to tournament tactics or
three days or what have you there's
still a lot of play in the position
overall I thought the position was still
a little bit in whites favor maybe but
not by much and again I would have
anticipated this type of
moves to have been played had the
players continue white obviously has in
his favor a king side majority getting
the night out of the way in order to use
it as important black has it in his
favor Queen site majority that really
isn't going anywhere at this moment so
that was why I like White's position
this was the only game that the two
players have played against one another
and it really is remarkable because
they're so high rated players that you
would have thought well for sure that
they would have played tons of games
with one another in 2014 the US
Championships came down to an exciting
dramatic finish when three players tied
for first and let's see oops I did it
wrong excuse me
three players tied for first Alex
Linderman gata kamsky and vara cobian
and because gada had really excellent
tiebreaks a cobian and lender Minh had
to play for the right to challenge him a
cobian one that that playoff and bar was
very very very determined he was in even
the best for chess form of his life he's
playing for the US Championship and you
couldn't ask for more motivated player
he was coming up against this incredible
veteran gata kamsky an incredible career
ghada has played for the world chess
championship you match he's been
involved in numerous candidates events
and he's played all of the best players
in the world it was only anatoly karpov
at his peak that really stopped gotta
from basically becoming world champion
so god knows what he's up against he and
ghana has this unbelievable lee cool
positional style it's like he has this
way of on the one hand provoking his
opponent into overreacting and
aggressively pursuing a an attack that
may not be there and it the same and he
has this way of lowly new to sleep and
making you think that the positions so
quite unbalanced and yet all the time he
is provoking you with these mettlesome
light moves and at the start of the
match we thought that VAR with white is
going to bring his a game and going to
try to white gotta off the board and
gada of course uses his
slav semi sloth set up and he's made
almost a career out of this last move a
7 a-6 as he's defended this position
numerous times and throughout his career
after a sex VAR played the most
aggressive variation he played the move
g2 g3 encouraging black to capture this
pot and to try to maintain the pond with
b5 so essentially a gambit got it
accepted and after nike5 got a very
calmly just said you can have the palm
back really sharp lines occur after for
example b5 Bishop this setup of along
the long diagonal here can be very
awkward or the second player you see a
lot of games where white tries to Blake
break up this majority with both the
moves a4 as well as b2 b3 black would be
under pressure and God I said don't want
anything to do with that I will just
play my quiet game g6 so bar one is bond
back Knight takes e4 and on the surface
it looks like well why it's pretty happy
I mean after all these pawns are not
great on the queenside over here a 6 and
c6
on a closer look however you discover
well black and really doesn't have any
weaknesses and after his next move
Bishop e6 the question is bish pardon me
Bishop g7 visions of bishop e6 the
question is are you so happy about
having your night on c4 if you play a
move for example like b2 b3 which looks
okay you might be a little bit worried
that you're opening up the diagonal for
the bishop forever maybe three c5 now
suddenly the benefit of this move a six
is made clear Bishop takes b7 doesn't
spear or up because the rook has a seven
squared out here so b2 b3 does not
impress queen d three I don't think that
that this move is very good in many
cattle and structures the queen is not
well placed on d3 c2 is this natural
well not d3 I don't like this move I
thought that bar should have just played
Knight e5 and after for example a move
like 97 he's have a choice whether he
wanted to keep to trade nights or
defendant isn't I me excuse me or to
defend his night and I thought that the
position would be basically balanced
however after Queen d3 with this very
nice move 95 suddenly Blacks game is
actually looking pretty good on the for
starters it has this idea of night
before attacking the Queen winning the
game on the spot the night on c4 would
be lost secondly with the night
dealing with that threat this Bishop on
g7 like in many many green fields is
actually looking really good excuse me
let me just do this is looking really
good on this diagonal and c6 c5 is
waiting to open up the diagonal for
black he saw night XD five Bishop takes
d5 Bishop takes d5 what to say already
White has a problem if he tries the move
e to e 4 we gotta take take an oopsie
Daisy there goes the palm Queen takes d4
and the position is in blacks favor
there was this work I before there
before we came I had this really nice
note
I wanted to share you share this with
you just let me go back to this moment
so this is where night before is the
problem so there's this really cool cute
little tactic a2 a3 just blocking the
night from moving to the be four square
no more night before that will DUP but
what about c5c five looks really really
strong for black because the moment you
see detex e5 Knight takes c3 you don't
want anything to do with this variation
as black again it's very important that
this pawn is on a six so that in many
lines Bishop takes b7 does not spear the
rook this in fact is winning for black
there we go back one move and we go
Knight takes d5
okay well its first sight this also
appears to be very bad for white but
it's not after Bishop takes d5 black has
two threads Bishop takes g2 pawn takes
d4 Bishop takes d4 looks great for black
but white has a fantastic move here I
like to invite our audience tell me do
you see a fantastic move for white while
you guys are thinking what white does to
save his position I'm just going to be
looking at the Twitter question
questions free yes is it yes i'll get to
that one thank you for the Twitter
question in fact yes the question was is
there a bobby fisher price as we know
Bobby Fischer won the US Championship
once with a perfect score of 11 0 I
always liked the the comment that Hans
comic the tournament director said at
the closing ceremony everybody was
having a dinner he came to the table
where Bobby was sitting along with
Grandmaster larry evans and hans cam
lock shook the hand of bobby fischer
congratulated him on his exhibition nope
first he shook the hand of larry evans
and congratulated him on his tournament
victory larry was second in the
tournament and then he shipped the hands
of Bobby Fischer and congratulated him
on his exhibition at the US
Championships there's a
sixty-four-thousand-dollar bonus prize
to anybody who can go perfect have a
perfect score in the field never before
has the Bobby Fisher Price been extended
to the women but this year it will be
there will be a
sixty-four-thousand-dollar bonus prize
to the to any woman who can go 11 and 0
in her competition did you guys find
White's move no it's beautiful and it's
very hidden 93 96 check whoa take a look
at that shot if you recapture with a
pawn then of course the bishop is
hanging on d5 so you recapture with the
Queen now I've learned the Queen to the
d 6 squared so that I can capture the
pawn so that after Queen takes Queen
takes white regains his peace and he
stands slightly better so that was a
trick I suspect at the board it's a it's
a trick if you're not familiar with
these cattle and type positions that
it's easy to miss and the move a 2 a 3 I
thought was a better choice than what
bar did which was trade trade and check
this out in no time all the minor pieces
came off and what's left an absolutely
cold symmetrical pawn structure and yet
who has the better of it black does
blacks bishop on g7 is simply excellent
the white Bishop is less of a attacking
force in the position and after more
moves gotta managed to get a slight
advantage this pieces were simply more
active than his opponent after all look
at that rook on C to the bishop on c3 is
very passive Julian
the question that Julian ass is why did
white castle and at the time the Queen's
were on the board bishop d two bishops
III very reasonable Bishop d2 and let's
just see here for a second let's say
black plays rook c8 and let's say black
plays Roxy fun
if you play B 3 III yeah sorry i was
going to say if you play be three maybe
the bishop could be a tad weakened if
you play III then likely blackwell
castle double rooks maybe treble rooks
on the c5 in short it's it's it's a pool
for black it's just the bishop on c3 is
not as comfortable as the one on g7 by
no means is the game losing or anything
like that but suddenly the advantage you
know it's like the opening advantage
just just shifted really run remarkably
again and I set it up at the start of
the bar you know really came into this
game with you know very high hopes of
putting the lack under pressure and he
fell under pressure quite quickly
himself positions a draw and I'm just
going to go through the move so you can
see what happened nothing really
happened a fortress type of setup was
created at the end neither player could
possibly do anything so this was how
this game ended in the draw this move
that meant that the US Championship the
title would depend on the next game
oops pardon me I forgot to do something
I apologize okay so now here's gotta
kamsky and again ghada has a very very
hard style to to to to isolate in fact
it's impossible because he you really
don't know what God is going to do you
can plug very very sharply he can play
any positionally in the style of the
Petrosyan and he can mix them that
virtually any time so again he's playing
of cobian VAR is you know all adrenaline
pumping you know wants to put pressure
on the defending champion once that
upset the defending champion he's got
his opportunity and let's see how gotta
play the opening gotta in fact played
the opening in the most boring style
that was absolutely possible he played
it incredibly incredibly quietly so much
so that already at this point black has
just simply fully equalized queen bee
three take stakes and the simplest and
it's really shocking that VAR did not do
this the simplest way of meeting this
attack against the pollen b7 was just to
offer the trade of Queens that's all I
really don't think either player has any
kind of advantage whatsoever after for
example a move let's just say c5 you can
drop back with the Queen and basically
what black intention is to just play
9075 trade a lot of pieces and make a
very comfortable draw
that did not happen bar plate 97
offering the pawn on b7 well why traded
nights let's just understand why this
would have been a very dubious decision
to go pawn hunting because after rook
takes be to black has some very nasty
ideas including Queen a5 this rook on b2
is enormously strong on the second ring
I'm upon grubber myself but even that
one that would be asking way too much of
the position so Knight takes e4 Bishop
takes e4 castles and again a very very
quiet position just a few minor pieces
have been trading nothing to talk about
at all but over the course of the next
10 moves an incredible transformation
happens literally white takes over the
game and he did it in a style that I can
only describe as goddess because I don't
know others who could do this 92 you
drove the bishop back nothing special
Queen a3 the Queen takes up a much
better square attacks the pawn on a
seven looks down the board over here
along the a3 diagonal a 7 a-6 look to
the center row to the center be for now
given a free hand white is just going to
move this queen queen bee three a4 b5
and get an app on roller going on on the
queenside to start his own counterplay
bar reacted with it a reaction in the
center
five
run again I'll just kind of take a quick
poll here how many audience to think is
still balanced like game looks pretty
equal how many think that white stands
better will wide in a very interesting
way does stand better and it has to do
with the pawn structure essentially and
very clearly black has a three to two
majority on the queenside excellent
except the majority is stuck a white
spawn on before is keeping all of those
pawns there on the other hand on the
King side why has a majority but they're
not stuck we'll see why first of all the
root comes to the center very clearly
rook takes up a great outpost in the
center supported by the extra kingside
poem for 23 majority
and just like that the game is really
really difficult for VAR at this point
essentially white has numerous threats
to mention but to one is just to play
Knight down to d6 triple along the D
file and with the night firmly planted
on d6 go f3 + e for killing two of the
miners on the King side so that's almost
like a strangle grip the second threat
is that white let me just clear this for
a second I'll go back the second threat
from White's point of view is to play
the move Knight a5 when the rooks come
to the defiled chop everything up trade
off all the major pieces that you can
and then the b7 pawn is a perpetual
weakness in an ending where there's only
two sets of minor pieces for each player
so far has a number of problems that
just appeared out of nowhere he tries to
play the move c6 he plays the move c65
trying to get rid of this pawn on before
which is hampering his Queen side
majority goddess says thank you very
much night comes in to d6 rook moves
over to f8 and suddenly night takes b7
and he says i forked your yoke and pawn
try to get some compensation for your
loss pawn well there is this problem
from White's point of view that the pop
of the night on these sevens in the pin
after the Queen went back to a7 this pin
was promptly broken by this very
powerful new group to be for the night
is no longer pin White's upon up
and black has to do something Bishop to
g4 night to d6 trade Bishop to e4 Knight
to f5 a really nasty moved this this
move Knight to f5 because it sets up a
really nice tactic I hope everybody sees
it but why didn't bark capture the pawn
on a two what's wrong with this tim i
know you know this one I know you know
this one it starts with a check see it
Gillian
yes very very nice 97 chat drives the
blacks King away from the protection of
the rook their king is forced to drop
into the corner check the king and the
rook is exposed and now white wins an
exchange and has a one position
essentially at this point so 9 f 5 sets
up that really nasty 97 check threat
black defended the threat and Queen f4
and here unfortunately for bar he didn't
see the second threat Julian bank Knight
takes g7 that was that that was all she
wrote and this is how gada kamsky won
the US Championship from last year he
picked up a second pawn the third pawn
and finally when it rains it pours
correct the DA check how many of you
fallen for this tactic by the way yeah
me too like three four times in my gate
like we was protected by the rook the
rook comes down again it gives me a
check in between the King in the room to
pick up the game so this is the Haggadah
camps key won the US Championship in
2014 2015 it's going to be a barn burner
I think it's just going to be a
fantastic event with the strongest field
ever two of the world's top ten half the
field in the top 100 unbelievable a
talented group
of youngsters in the field this is the
most talented generation that I can ever
recall and I came from a very talented
group of Grand Masters in my 1976 us
Junior Championship of the eight players
in the field but the player who won the
tournament was Mark decent he went on to
become an international master but he
also won the world junior championship
today today if you win the world junior
championship under 21 they give you the
Grand Master title mark deserve to get
the Grand Master title because he he
went from the US Junior Championship to
the world junior championship six of the
other seven players in the field became
grandmasters from John fedora wits
Michael road Jonathan Tisdale mukhda
fermion ron henley the eighth live in
the field internet became an
international master went on to become a
professor of mathematics kenneth regan
so out of an eight-player round robin
six became grandmasters and two became
international masters but when i look at
this field of junior players and Ray
Robson and Sam shanklin are really
juniors there already collegiate they're
so young and looking at this field with
kaden and
Sam I just have to say this is really
really going to be a great US
Championship I hope you'll join us here
in st. Louis if you can make the visit
it's going to be well worth your while
and if you can watches in the u.s. chest
champs calm I hope you enjoyed the
lecture to this evening we'll try to do
more with image try to work out all the
kinks of the lecture and try to do them
maybe on a monthly basis and we will
welcome your input and what kind of
things you would like us to cover most
whether they be tournament competitions
players openings middle games tactics
let us know thank you and have a lovely
evening
you